all right let's get a game in here
against uh miss click gambit
all right for a rapid
all right
so
those of you challenging me with the
10-0
i know it's very tempting
to want to tune in while we play i would
appreciate it if you don't though you
could always look back
those uh my past broadcasts are
accessible to everybody not just
subscribers so
all right let's go
miss click gambit
10-0
a viewer game a 10-0
all right
so these games won't uh
be a step
i won't be anywhere closer to getting
rid of the question mark
with the uh casual
how do i want to begin
can i do something that's different
maybe we try b6
that's different
uh the battle of the question marks
actually we don't know
we got a multiple question marks there
for miss click gambit
so not enough games in i guess
all right
let's start with knight
here
you gotta be careful
could easily get overwhelmed in the
center
um
this makes sense put this guy right here
like this kind of stuff
you know
putting a pawn on d5
that can be painful
now what am i doing if d5 is played by
the way
i don't know if i have a great answer to
that one
and i think i'd want to challenge it
with either e6 or c6 i'd
be leaning more towards e6
so that this guy could come out and have
an influence on the knight which has
control over these
light squares
so
if i play my
if i play e6 right now
there is e4 but e4 is basically saying
i am okay with giving up my dark square
bishop
here e4 h6 if you back off i break the
pin and then i win out on e4
so we'll see what the decision will be
by white
will they
uh try and
uh build a center and be okay with
giving up the bishop or not
it's in or not
in this case e3
content with the solid
setup all right
how to approach it from here
bishop b4
uh h6
uh d5 is another move
i may want to play bishop e7
i don't know how big a fan i am of
bishop to b4
i think i'll uh
i'll go with something simple
we're going to break a pin
i'm just saying in the chat key logan
is miss click gambit and they said that
the stream is muted of course okay
i'm going to take key logan's
i'm going to i'm going to say that
being an
honest
and honest guy there
okay
oh here's another thing
i think i could play c5 now
i think i'm gonna go with c5
so what's the
thing
here here's the thing i have to be
careful about c5
because of d5
however
if d5 is played now i could take
and if they chop here i get to sweep on
back
with the recapture
boom boom boom
i get to take here
i have to challenge this duo in some way
this seems to be
fine
i'm
still retaining options with my d-pawn
one or two i don't know i may want to
first capture
see how white recaptures and only then
make my decision with my d-pawn
so right here
i think i may want to chop
i don't know at any point at what point
if it's a good time right now to flick
in the flight square
i'm leaning more towards capturing
be a bit careful about my h7 pawn
i don't think i'll begin with that
capture
all right
and i think d5
opening myself up to a check
but
i think it should be fine
step my queen up
tell you what let me let me
go with this move right now maybe maybe
i should have uh
clicked in h6 before the capture let's
go with this right now
oh okay well this this changes things a
whole lot we have another imbalance i
was expecting this
why i went with h6
um before castling was so that h4 is
isn't maybe a possibility
so that's
there's a takeaway there for sure
um
can be a quite aggressive move
all right what am i waiting for i really
want to consider taking with the pawn
i don't think so
we're keeping the pawnees as is
so i have the two bees
in some positions i may be threatening
to win the d4 pawn but not here the
recapture hits this guy in the corner
so dark squares dark squares dark
squares
let's keep in mind
that color complex
we have an unopposed dark square bishop
so
white
is maybe a little vulnerable there
d4
does not have pawn support so this
always has to be
watched out for
defended by pieces and if it moves
this guy's eyes open
even wider
also this knight's eyes light up a bit
more as well
to the c5 square if this pawn ever
budges
um
i'm thinking white will castle i guess
other moves are bishop or knight to e4
maybe d5
maybe a decision with the queen
queen e2 here
if i were to capture the queen
recaptures
okay that move i didn't consider at all
huh
okay you're clearly looking at the d6
square
i could play d6 to stop the knight from
diving in there
could play d5 as well any pawn move
defends d6
any d-pawn move
i'm leaning more
towards one step
uh here is that a move
[Music]
yeah maybe
yeah maybe
d5 here and there's a support point
i think i'm i'll just go one step
small pawn center
i still retain
options two different possible breaks
it remains open
i want to be careful
maybe better state i want to be careful
about creating ram structures
if i have this
this asset tipping in my favor the
bishop pair
i shouldn't describe it as an asset
let's just say i have the bishop here i
want to be careful about creating
ram structures pawns that are
immobile
butting heads
so for right now this knight isn't uh
coordinated with any other piece queen
a4
is setting up a discovery i could castle
and if queen here here trying to
coordinate there i could defend that
with bishop to e7 so things are nice and
cozy on the king's side this is a
healthy structure small pawn center
bishop's eyes remain opened
i think in this environment the bishops
are thriving
candidate moves for white include
still looking at castles i think it's
turning out the knight on
b5 if there isn't a good follow-up if
there isn't a great way to connect with
this knight it
it turns out to be a
wasted move
it would be different if this guy was
here and you could follow up i don't
know what
with c5 straight away and really look to
sink that knight in there but not really
seeing that so they're setting up
discovery land
let's get out of that
that's got to be a poison pawn
they're in a pickle that i
don't see them getting out of
i could be helpful in playing knight c6
because they get to take and be on my
queen but i wouldn't play knight c6 what
would i play
maybe that and then this
and then uh
maybe i'd be threatening b5 then with
the bishop hitting the knight on a7 okay
so now
now
this is definitely
problemo
now's the time to flush this night away
i am threatening the knight
do have defense of the rook there is no
pin on the a file
and i'll be taking out this pawn next
nothing exciting happening against my
king that i see
the queen is
queen side committed
i don't see her shifting over quickly to
the king side
i'm thinking not at all about winning
this pawn i'd much rather the center
pawn i
don't want to
unnecessarily create
a half open file
towards my king
really only seeing this is the move
there's some other move
what else would hurt me
well that's the wrong phrase
i'm not seeing a move that's going to
hurt me here
is there something better than knight c3
bishop something that attacks my
unprotected bishop
but
uh if actually this i could shut the
door on that idea with d5
and then
we're gonna have
two
minor pieces attacked so maybe that's
what's
being calculated right now here maybe
they're only looking at the capture and
after this
then uh you know i'd be in the pin
because my rook wouldn't be defended
but
i i could simply take here
what am i missing
take the knight
the old inbetweener
take with the queen
queen could take here too
all right
a knight for a pawn imbalance
i take on d4 i'm looking for
clean technique not like in that last
blitz game
or blundered a rook
what exciting things is the queen gonna
do
i'm gonna take here
defend b6
i want the queens off i'm on the bishop
i'm threatening a
check that's covered
i'm on the bishop i'm
threatening to queen exchange
queenside castle
threatens this
maybe i take there
yeah still i don't even i don't even
want i don't want material i want uh
okay they resigned i'm just looking for
some clarity i'm looking for exchanges
from here on out
my opponent resigned okay good game this
was key logan in the chat
mr miss click gambit
um
good game let's have a let's have a look
at it
rapid
rapid viewer game
somebody already ran the analysis
so
yeah well it's a slower game so i got to
basically share everything that i wanted
to
maybe there isn't so much to go over
yeah oh something here let's say castles
and then uh yeah this rook move if i
play h6 is h4 move
it blinked for a second
h4
his h4 move
it's a move i don't know how
scary it would be for me in fact i don't
actually let me go back i don't know
about the rook move let's say a queen
move instead
keeping open the option to queenside
castle and now if i play h6 h4
h4 is is is a move right if i'm taking
that that's poison
plus two
okay that's at least one takeaway
from this game
uh a reason to uh delay castling there
yeah this is where white really started
to go astray with the knight to b4 idea
okay
all right good game key logan
you